démultiplier les possibilités pour la
retransmission d'événements sportifs
voilà une application du projet
expérimental de la 5g au vélodrome
nationale des apparitions d'information
en réalité augmentée durant une
rencontre sportive ou encore
l'utilisation de l'art mode production
une évolution importante pour xd motion
on à l'utilisation maintenant de la 5g
pour pouvoir piloter à distance nos
systèmes donc ça c'est la grosse
évolution qui est en préparation on
reviendra dessus pour les jo de paris
2001 cas là ce que vous voyez c'est la
grande vitesse de déplacement du ce
qu'on appelle 2x lie un des câbles
calmes sur lequel nous avons rajouté
l'arrêté augmente et donc je vous
expliquais les tendances du marché et de
son évolution donc la remote production
et la réalité augmentée donc tous les
graphismes virtuel qui vient d'être
ajouté
c'est je dirais les prémices de ce qui
va être utilisé par la suite sur parler
de 1024 x démotion c'est une société de
production audiovisuelle
implantée à coignières elle fait partie
du consortium 5 g avec nokia qualcomm
technologies ou encore france
télévisions actuellement xd motion
travail sur les jeux olympiques d'hiver
apic un mois depuis maintenant les jeux
d'albertville donc ça remonte quand même
en 92
les effectivement les jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 aujourd'hui on les a
tous couverts on part on vient de finir
tokyo avec tous les drones qui ont été
qui ont été utilisés là bas sur place et
en chine on nous avons tourné tout les
sports extrêmes avec nos technologies
cablecom pas le temps de souffler
puisque les premiers tests grandeur
nature au vélodrome nationales auront
lieu ce sera du tout au 16 octobre
durant les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste